Spider-Man and Venom: two great
tastes that taste great together.
"Yummy."
The multiverse
cracked wide open in "Spider-Man: No Way Home,"
paving the way for all sorts of characters,
bad and good, to make the leap across franchises
and enter the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
In a crossover foreshadowed by the
post-credits scene of Sony's "Venom:
Let There Be Carnage," the Lethal Protector
himself shows up in the first post-credits scene
of "No Way Home," which it picks up shortly
after the "Venom" sequel's shocking tease.
After seeming to cross universes in "Let There Be
Carnage," and seeing a news report
about Tom Holland's Spider-Man,
"No Way Home" definitively confirms that Venom
and Eddie Brock were pulled into the MCU.
The "No Way Home" footage shows Eddie and Venom
seated at a bar, as the symbiote's human host
comes to terms with everything MCU-related.
That includes Thanos, the Infinity Stones,
Iron Man, and the Blip, thanks to a patient
bartender who's there to explain it all.
But when Eddie suggests that he and Venom
go and see Spider-Man in New York to talk
about their situation, he and Venom are
suddenly pulled back to their universe.
These events leave fans with a pretty
big question after the dramatic events
of "Spider-Man: No Way Home": Will Venom
ever come face-to-face with Spider-Man?
Some form of Venom and Spider-Man fighting one
another on screen again seems like a sure thing,
not only because they've fought
in the world of Marvel Comics,
but also because Sony Pictures holds the rights
to both the Spider and the Symbiote. The only
potential roadblock here is Marvel Studios head
Kevin Feige and the studio's plans for the MCU.
"The entire relationship between Sony and
Marvel and Disney is really unprecedented
in Hollywood history, and it's all
because everyone loves Spider-Man."
Thankfully, Sony and Marvel seem to have formed a
solid working relationship, so it's highly likely
Tom Holland and Tom Hardy will share the
screen in a Marvel adventure at some point.
That said, it's not hard to throw two Marvel
characters together and shout "Fight!"
A compelling plot will go a long way to making the
meeting of these two figures feel natural. After
all, a lot of legwork had to be done to get them
in the same universe, let alone the same arena.
The most important thing seems to be carving
out a story for their matchup that makes sense.
"Please, Scooby-Doo this crap."
When asked about the prospect of
a crossover in the wake of "Venom: Let There
Be Carnage," Holland told Total Film Magazine,
"I genuinely don't know. It was really
exciting to be a part of that film. Obviously,
Tom Hardy is one of the greatest actors in the
world. I'm happy to say that he's a lovely bloke.
But I haven't really given it very much thought."
Meanwhile, back in August, Hardy told Esquire,
"I would be remiss if I wasn't trying to
steer any kind of connectivity. Obviously,
that's a large canyon to leap, to be bridged by
one person alone, and it would take a much higher
level of diplomacy and intelligence, sitting down
and talking, to take on an arena such as that."
The only question left to ask is how the
two characters might meet up in the future,
and the answer possibly lies in the "No
Way Home" post-credits scene. When Eddie
is yanked out of the MCU, he leaves
behind a small piece of the Symbiote
on the bar. It feels like a safe bet that
that bit of black goo will find its way,
one way or another, to Peter Parker.
Depending on what happens to that dollop
of symbiote, Venom could theoretically have
a face-off with Spider-Man in the MCU now,
whether Tom Hardy is involved or not. And now
that the multiverse has been blown open for
both characters, Eddie Brock could well make
a return visit in the future, or vice versa.
Venom tells Eddie in "Let There Be Carnage" that
the Symbiote Collective Mind knows all about
the multiverse already. If a fight is in the
cards for them, Venom at least would be ready.
This all leaves us with just one question:
Who wins in a fight between Tom Holland's
Spider-Man and Tom Hardy's Venom?
That's a topic for another day.
"On my planet, I am kind of a loser,
like you. But here, we could be more."
"Excuse me?"
Check out one of our newest videos
right here! Plus, even more Looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.